oh oh oh oh ça fait du bien quand ça
s'arrête
didon j'en ai plein les oreilles
je suis complètement abrutis moi je vais
devenir sur wii ses voisins du dessus ma
force de passer l'aspirateur à n'importe
quelle heure non ma mort au lycée et
belge est drôlement bien aimé le moment
où tu m'a touché c'est à dire que bon ça
faisait trois heures qu'on discute et
qu'on se regarde est alors j'ai passé
avec oui oui mais m'a étonné as tu m'a
drôlement surprise parce que je pensais
pas qu'autant les vrais ton pyjama ça tu
as fait quelque chose
bah oui parce que j'aille pattes étaient
tatoués
on remarque cependant un vrai tatouage
c'est un dessin que j'ai fait moi-même à
l'encré avec mon stylo plume pour
t'exciter non mais dis donc pour exciter
à seksik drôlement bien sexy gala
curiosité parce qu'on se demande ce que
c'est on sait abstrait c'est un symbole
qui relance des pulsions indépendamment
de ton toit au niveau ton désir sur mon
moi ah tu croiras ben ali dont moi je
voulais savoir aussi quelque chose
j'aurais voulu savoir si tu préférais
quand j'étais dessus ou dans une des
deux sous ah ah bon bah bah moi si tu
veux pas parce que si tu veux bon de
toute façon quand il y en a un au dessus
l'autre et dessous
et inversement mais pour dormir c'est
mieux sur le côté tu sais moi j'ai lu
dans un livre dans un manuel que il ya
des gens aiment et ils s'attachent à bah
oui bah c'est normal si tu es une fois
que tu as vu l'autre tenu bon bah tu
t'attaches à lui harry non mais non mais
non mais il s'attache fils attaque
solide cote
ah bon c'est pourquoi tombés de leur lit
en tout cas j'ai adoré quand tu m'a
prise tout à l'heure à quel moment
pendant le dîner avec ta mère a les
photos sont bien réussis ça va être
chouette mais c'est bien toute façon les
préliminaires c'est important tout ce
qu'on fait avant si on s'amuse bien si
on passe une bonne soirée tout ça si on
fait du sport avant comme l'autre soir
après souper
quand j'ai eu l'idée qu'on aille courir
20 km dans la forêt de fontainebleau bas
après on a bien un traitement bien on a
bien dormi ouais tu vois c'que important
si c'est les aphrodisiaques
moi j'aime bien quand tu nous prépares
de du boudin antillais à la purée de
piments rouges
et qu'on mange avec des grandes karting
de moutarde et en dessert chacun une
bonne livre de gingembre confit au
poivre vert
et puis en plus avec tous avaient une
bonne volée de vinaigre là dessus pour
faire descendre le doubs à la et bien
remarqué aussi des aphrodisiaques
qu'exit la vue eh ouais les photos ça on
devrait tapisser la chambre de photos
oui on devra remettre des photos comme
les photos qu'on a vu tu sais l'autre
jour au sex shop là tu sais et les trucs
là avec différents modèles tout ça pour
en mettre des photos comme ça les photos
par exemple avec des hommes avec des
femmes avec les animaux y avait des
animaux si c'est pas la peine puisque on
a déjà au mur le canevas nous à faire ta
mère ça représente 10 ch oui j'oubliais
aussi algorithmes sur le calendrier des
postes abbaoui tu vois il d'envoyer une
position que j'ai bien aimer l'autre
soir je m'étais coincé la tête dans le
tiroir de la table de nuit
j'avais les pieds sur la poignée de la
porte de chambre
ah ouais mais je m'en souviens pas que
celle-là moins abondante et épaules
comme à tous ces gains truc que j'adore
ça ça fait complètement complètement
frémir c'est quand tu prends ton élan du
dessus de l'armoire loges le jeu même en
eau coule alors la saq fois lorsque
chaque fois c'est bon là lors à chaque
fois tu l'a signé j'en ai marre j'en ai
même tuer de une fois oui voilà la vie
dont moi ce que j'adore encore plus
alors là c'est quand tu parles pendant
la shoah
quand je te bon je te dis que j'aime des
pieds et puis ce qui est drôlement bien
chez nous au niveau du couple c'est que
on a fait le tour du sexe ah oui ça on
en a bien fait ou fera 10 dons et puis
par exemple toujours plus sur sa chance
et chaque fois on maîtrise la chose d
fera mouche et puis on l'a réinventons
réinvente la chaussée hier on a vu une
couverture rouge sur le lit et ben
aujourd'hui une crédit commun et quant
aux places et pour les idées qu'ils nous
mentent et la table de nuit
la top de nuit demain avance 20 me et
après demain
et bien parce que je sais faire c'est
mettre le son staff au surlendemain le
chien ne regarde
et pour le week-end on mettra sept
minutes clair
vous connais un peu maintenant et j'ai
senti votre appréhension au départ rien
qu'à l'énoncé du sujet vous êtes
rassurés oui sur assurément ça a été
d'une grande pudeur ou et oui vous savez
qui a dit il avait placé sa main là où
il n'ya rien chez elle et elle avait
placé la sienne là où ce n'était pas
tout à fait de même chez lui qu'elle est
drôle il ya toute une littérature
érotique littéraire que vous connaissez
admirablement ou oui vous aussi
apollinaire diderot etc
r je crois que tous les grands les
grands auteurs se sont même amusés à
mettre un peu de beurre dans le chemin
de l'humour à partir de de l'eros moins
bon et bien je vous invite à revenir
demain ce sera demain le dernier jour de
la promotion francis huster ce sera le
bouquet la peau n'a pas parlé - l'un
parlait plus ou moins pour une fois on
en parlera demain